robbie ray is back at it and he couldn't
pitch any better than he did against the
tampa bay rays robbie takes a 7-4 record
with that era down to 3-13 in his 17
stars
as kind of aleppo swings into misses at
a fastball up one down
full count pitch lifted in the air left
center field not that deep and george
springer the center fielder takes charge
the base is empty for adolesce garcia
rookie center fielder and he was in
swing mode right away big leg kick early
he pops up the first pitch marcus simeon
makes the catch behind the bag and it's
a nice one two three top of the first
for robbie ray jordan lyle's numbers
this season a and five record
4.86 era and an opponent's batting
average of 287
and that ball is hit hard out into left
field but eli white is there as he goes
back a few steps to his left to haul in
the line drive and simeon is the first
down here in the bottom half of the
first inning
and he hits this ball hard out to left
and white getting a workout out there
but he makes another nice play all right
and now the the young star of the
american league vladimir guerrero jr
guerrero lifts one to left field and
gone
boy he didn't come close to getting all
of that and he still hit it out number
29 on the season for vladi
three batters
three hard hit balls already jordan
lyles is going to have to come up with a
different game plan because the blue
jays have been all over them charlie
culberson getting his start at third
base tonight for the rangers culberson
rips one over the leap of the third
baseman vizio down the left field line
to base it big turnaround first for
culverson hernandez has thrown a second
knot in time as culverson slides in
safely and the ranger is beginning the
top of the third with a double
one-two bounce to third vigil coming
home and in plenty of time to get the
sliding culverson at the plate
not really understanding that move right
there by the texas rangers you've got
two all-stars coming up in garcia and
gallo and you're running the contact
play with the infield in he's got no
chance to beat this throw top of the
order means marcus simeon and now he
gets a fastball turns on it and bounces
it to left field for a long home run his
23rd on the season it is two to nothing
blue jays
and when you wait
and make sure they come into you good
things are going to happen you wouldn't
bite on those sliders off the plate
he waited for the fastball and got one
middle in and that's a pitch that he has
been hitting
with regularity and hitting it hard and
hitting it far for the last three months
guerrero the lead at first two down and
the first pitch to t oscar hernandez is
swung on and hit down the left field
line and gone
a rocket to left field that got out in
the blink of an eye and it is four to
nothing blue jays
well it sure looked like to me that he
was waiting for that breaking ball
he struck out his first time up looking
on a pitch that he thought was down his
plan was i gotta look for another
breaking ball and that swing suggests
that
he got the pitch he was looking for
because he put a charge into that thing
and you're right that was a line drive
that got out of here quickly weight back
weight back inside hanging breaking ball
third home run of the night for the blue
jays and it's four to nothing there's
randall grichik
richik gets into one it's carrying and
it's gone
the third home run of the inning the
fourth of the ball game and the lead
keeps on growing back to back
this time
simeon led off for the home run day
oscar homer and now randall right behind
him that breaking ball is not doing
anything it's just staying over the
middle of the play
saying hit me and blue jays are not
missing it as we go to the fourth inning
gallow heim and low
2-2 pitch and a swing and a miss scallow
strikes out for the first out of the
fourth good looking fastball in another
swing and miss on a fastball for
robbie ray we highlighted that in her
open and how good he has been one of the
best in the league 2-2
and a bouncer to first guerrero's got it
and he'll go to the bag himself in
plenty of time for the second half 1-2
and he got him nasty slider down and
away fourth strike out of the night for
robbie ray
here's simeon
this ball struck pretty well to center
field short hops the wall
and that'll be a double for marcus
simeon it's here's bechet
and now bechet lines one into left field
for a base hit simeon coming around
third heading home
and he is safe at the plate
a very close play and jonah heim the
catcher just kind of staring at greg
gibson trying to figure out the call but
it goes the blue jays way at least for
the moment there were a little bit of
fireworks between innings greg gibson
the home plate umpire
engaged in a conversation i believe with
charlie montoya
and an argument ensues and charlie
montoya got tossed out of the game and
boy you i mean you never see that kind
of emotion that kind of anger out of
charlie montoya it looked like it had
something to do with the replay it was a
long time getting the replay
back to the umpire and the umpire had
something to say about it like you took
too long or you got two you know you
only have so much time
swinging a miss to get him one down on
the fifth strike out of the night for
ray
ray gets a call on the outside corner to
ring up gallow and retire the side and
another pitcher out of the bullpen for
the rangers right-hander dennis santana
is into the game so the blue jays with
the runners at first and second with a
one out for beshet
and he slashes this one to right field
and that's over the head of gallow and
off the wall on a bounce
maguire around third digging for home
and he's in there standing up around a
third comes simeon on a long rbi single
for bushette it is seven to nothing
first and third for vladimir guerrero
junior
guerrero turns on one
hits it to deep left field and gohan
right on out of the ballpark
for his second home run of the game he
is something else
my
oh my
if this is their last home stand here in
buffalo the blue jays are giving the
fans a treat and lady
is leading them
that thing was a thing of beauty knocked
it all the way out of the ballpark and
one thing i think we should all get used
to not just the home runs
in the pitch for the blue jays the
right-hander jacob barnes who is on for
the 26th time it is his seventh
appearance since being acquired by
toronto rudder at first nobody out a two
and two count
this ball hit pretty well center field
and that is gone
a two run shot by eli white
and the rangers at long last
get on the board they avoid the shutout
the mislocation here on 96 miles an hour
it's still not a terrible pitch that's
middle in that's just a really nice job
by eli white to pull the hands and watch
him here and how quick he is to get the
barrel on it was well blowed a two-run
homer by white so they are an out away
now isaiah kind of the left of the
battery is one
four the shots got it on the first and
ground ball for
that's your ball game
the blue jays come out flying post
all-star break
swinging the bats well robbie ray
terrific and a 10-2 win over the texas
rangers to go to 46 and 42 on the season